Hey everyone. If I had to choose just
one topic that makes all of the others
in linear algebra start to click, and
which too often goes unlearned the first
time a student takes linear algebra, it
would be this one. The idea of a linear
transformation and its relation to
matrices.
For this video, I'm just going to focus
on what these transformations look like
in the case of two dimensions and how
they relate to the idea of matrix vector
multiplication.
In particular, I want to show you a way
to think about matrix vector
multiplication that doesn't rely on
memorization.
To start, let's just parse this term,
linear transformation.
Transformation is essentially a fancy
word for function. It's something that
takes in inputs and spits out an output
for each one.
Specifically, in the context of linear
algebra, we like to think about
transformations that take in some vector
and spit out another vector.
So, why use the word transformation
instead of function if they mean the
same thing?
Well, it's to be suggestive of a certain
way to visualize this input-output
relation. You see, a great way to
understand functions of vectors is to
use movement.
If a transformation takes some input
vector to some output vector, we imagine
that input vector moving over to the
output vector.
Then to understand the transformation as
a whole, we might imagine watching every
possible input vector move over to its
corresponding output vector.
It gets really crowded to think about
all of the vectors all at once, each one
is an arrow. So, as I mentioned last
video, a nice trick is to conceptualize
each vector not as an arrow, but as a
single point, the point where its tip
sits.
That way, to think about a
transformation taking every possible
input vector to some output vector, we
watch every point in space moving to
some other point.
In the case of transformations in two
dimensions, to get a better feel for the
whole shape of the transformation, I
like to do this with all of the points
on an infinite grid.
I also sometimes like to keep a copy of
the grid in the background just to help
keep track of where everything ends up
relative to where it starts.
The effect for various transformations
moving around all of the points in space
is, you've got to admit, beautiful.
It gives the feeling of squishing and
morphing space itself.
As you can imagine, though, arbitrary
transformations can look pretty
complicated. But luckily, linear algebra
limits itself to a special type of
transformation, ones that are easier to
understand, called linear
transformations.
Visually speaking, a transformation is
linear if it has two properties. All
lines must remain lines without getting
curved, and the origin must remain fixed
in place.
For example, this right here would not
be a linear transformation since the
lines get all curvy.
And this one right here, although it
keeps the line straight, is not a linear
transformation because it moves the
origin.
This one here fixes the origin and it
might look like it keeps lines straight,
but that's just because I'm only showing
the horizontal and vertical grid lines.
When you see what it does to a diagonal
line, it becomes clear that it's not at
all linear since it turns that line all
curvy.
In general, you should think of linear
transformations as keeping grid lines
parallel and evenly spaced.
Some linear transformations are simple
to think about, like rotations about the
origin. Others are a little trickier to
describe with words.
So, how do you think you could describe
these transformations numerically? If
you were, say, programming some
animations to make a video teaching the
topic, what formula do you give the
computer so that if you give it the
coordinates of a vector, it can give you
the coordinates of where that vector
lands?
It turns out that you only need to
record where the two basis vectors, I
hat and J hat, each land, and everything
else will follow from that.
For example, consider the vector V with
coordinates -1 2, meaning that it equals
-1 * I hat + 2 * J hat.
If we apply some transformation and
follow where all three of these vectors
go, the property that grid lines remain
parallel and evenly spaced has a really
important consequence.
The place where V lands will be -1 * the
vector where I hat landed + 2 * the
vector where J hat landed. In other
words, it started off as a certain
linear combination of I hat and J hat,
and it ends up as that same linear
combination of where those two vectors
landed.
This means you can deduce where V must
go based only on where I hat and J hat
each land.
This is why I like keeping a copy of the
original grid in the background. For the
transformation shown here, we can read
off that I hat lands on the coordinates
1 -2,
and J hat lands on the x-axis over at
the coordinates 3 0.
This means that the vector represented
by -1 I hat + 2 * J hat ends up at -1 *
the vector 1 -2 + 2 * the vector 3 0.
Adding that all together, you can deduce
that it has to land on the vector 5 2.
This is a good point to pause and ponder
cuz it's pretty important.
Now, given that I'm actually showing you
the full transformation, you could have
just looked to see that V has the
coordinates 5 2, but the cool part here
is that this gives us a technique to
deduce where any vectors land so long as
we have a record of where I hat and J
hat each land without needing to watch
the transformation itself.
Write the vector with more general
coordinates x and y,
and it will land on x * the vector where
I hat lands, 1 -2,
+ y * the vector where J hat lands, 3 0.
Carrying out that sum, you see that it
lands at 1x + 3y, -2x + 0y.
I give you any vector, and you can tell
me where that vector lands using this
formula.
What all of this is saying is that a
two-dimensional linear transformation is
completely described by just four
numbers, the two coordinates for where I
hat lands and the two coordinates for
where J hat lands. Isn't that cool?
It's common to package these coordinates
into a 2x2 grid of numbers called a 2x2
matrix, where you can interpret the
columns as the two special vectors where
I hat and J hat each land.
If you're given a 2x2 matrix describing
a linear transformation and some
specific vector, and you want to know
where that linear transformation takes
that vector,
you can take the coordinates of the
vector,
multiply them by the corresponding
columns of the matrix, then add together
what you get.
This corresponds with the idea of adding
the scaled versions of our new basis
vectors.
Let's see what this looks like in the
most general case where your matrix has
entries a b c d.
And remember, this matrix is just a way
of packaging the information needed to
describe a linear transformation. Always
remember to interpret that first column
a c as the place where the first basis
vector lands, and that second column b d
as the place where the second basis
vector lands.
When we apply this transformation to
some vector x y, what do you get?
Well, it'll be x * a c + y * b d.
Putting this together, you get a vector
ax + by, cx + dy.
You could even define this as matrix
vector multiplication when you put the
matrix on the left of the vector like
it's a function.
Then, you could make high schoolers
memorize this without showing them the
crucial part that makes it feel
intuitive.
But isn't it more fun to think about
these columns as the transformed
versions of your basis vectors, and to
think about the result as the
appropriate linear combination of those
vectors?
Let's practice describing a few linear
transformations with matrices.
For example, if we rotate all of space
90° counterclockwise, then I hat lands
on the coordinates 0 1.
And J hat lands on the coordinates -1 0.
So, the matrix we end up with has
columns 0 1, -1 0.
To figure out what happens to any vector
after a 90° rotation, you could just
multiply its coordinates by this matrix.
Here's a fun transformation with a
special name, called a shear.
In it, I hat remains fixed, so the first
column of the matrix is 1 0, but J hat
moves over to the coordinates 1 1, which
become the second column of the matrix.
And at the risk of being redundant here,
figuring out how a shear transforms a
given vector comes down to multiplying
this matrix by that vector.
Let's say we want to go the other way
around, starting with a matrix, say with
columns 1 2 and 3 1, and we want to
deduce what its transformation looks
like. Pause and take a moment to see if
you can imagine it.
One way to do this is to first move I
hat to 1 2,
then move J hat to 3 1, always moving
the rest of space in such a way that
keeps grid lines parallel and evenly
spaced.
If the vectors that I hat and J hat land
on are linearly dependent, which, if you
recall from last video, means that one
is a scaled version of the other, it
means that the linear transformation
squishes all of 2D space onto the line
where those two vectors sit, also known
as the one-dimensional span of those two
linearly dependent vectors.
To sum up, linear transformations are a
way to move around space such that grid
lines remain parallel and evenly spaced,
and such that the origin remains fixed.
Delightfully, these transformations can
be described using only a handful of
numbers, the coordinates of where each
basis vector lands. Matrices give us a
language to describe these
transformations, where the columns
represent those coordinates, and matrix
vector multiplication is just a way to
compute what that transformation does to
a given vector.
The important takeaway here is that
every time you see a matrix, you can
interpret it as a certain transformation
of space.
Once you really digest this idea, you're
in a great position to understand linear
algebra deeply. Almost all of the topics
coming up, from matrix multiplication to
determinants, change of basis,
eigenvalues, all of these will become
easier to understand once you start
thinking about matrices as
transformations of space.
Most immediately, in the next video,
I'll be talking about multiplying two
matrices together. See you then.
[Music]